Dominique bien sûr ma femme c'est c'est
elle qui
on partage à deux cette cette aventure à
chaque fois hein c'est elle est
aujourd'hui la directrice générale de de
comment dire du groupe quelque part elle
a une une fonction une un rôle très
important en tout cas moi je m'occupe
vraiment de ce qui est cuisine je reste
dans dans mon domaine elle elle gère
tout le reste et c'est c'est une partie
qui est très importante donc on est un
vrai binôme on a une vraie équipe on est
on est on est on est des qu'on peut dire
ça on peut on est on est des partenaires
quoi voilà aussi
des roses en chocolat pour la séduire
c'est vrai vous avez galéré je crois
pour les roses
mais si vous a demandé mais c'est après
après c'est elle qui vous a demandé en
mariage oui c'est vrai ouais c'est vrai
c'est elle qui m'a demandé en mariage
ouais j'étais vrai exact vous
ingrédients pour durer 24 ans de mariage
je sais pas qu'est-ce que c'est je crois
beaucoup de beaucoup de complicité il y
a beaucoup de beaucoup de dialogues
aussi alors moi je serais un petit peu
voilà j'aurais un côté un peu peut-être
un peu un peu tes yeux je suis pas
quelqu'un qui qui parle beaucoup mais
Dominique elle en a besoin elle parle
beaucoup donc elle me elle m'amène aussi
justement à voir ces échanges qui
effectivement sont importants et qui
permettent de durer voilà c'est c'est
bien moi je suis très très fier très
fier d'elle très fière de très fier de
ce qu'elle fait de ce qu'elle m'apporte
aussi parce que je dois pas être facile
au quotidien aussi j'ai quelqu'un comme
moi c'est pas simple à suivre et
Dominique est là pour canaliser un peu
tout ça
et c'est bien et c'est important je vois
de plus en plus même encore aujourd'hui
elle m'apporte beaucoup de choses elle
me fait réfléchir aussi ce que je ne
fais pas toujours et c'est bien c'est
c'est finalement ça crée un vrai
équilibre